do we find in the Old Testament Canon
not the truncated shorter Cannon adopted
by the reformers even though they still
kept the D chronical books in their
Bibles they still print them with their
Bibles and it wasn't until the 19th
century 1830s that Protestant Bible
Publishers
stopped including the D chonicles in
their Protestant Bibles but up until the
19th century 1800s 1830s even with the
King James up to the 1880s all the
Protestant Bibles including King James
had these books but anyway let's see do
we find
intercession in the untruncated
Bible yeah now don't forget Protestants
don't forget anti-catholics anti-
Orthodox even if you don't
accept these books of scripture there
are still Jewish books that there are
still books written by Jews and this is
reflective of the practices and Theology
of some if not most Jews before the time
of Christ in other words even if you
don't accept this book as scripture
you're going to have to contend with the
fact that the Jews who read your 39 Old
Testament books had no problem praying
for the dead and believing that prophets
and holy men are still alive in the
afterlife praying for them it is the Jew
Jewish belief not a pagan belief you
with me there
m second mbes 15 11-1 17 now what I'm
want to do is I want to have you read it
for me so I can sa my voice can you read
it yeah all right he armed each of them
not so much with confidence in Shields
and Spears as with the inspiration of
Brave words and he cheered them all by
relating a dream a sort of vision which
was worthy of belief what he saw was
this anas who had been high priest a
noble and good man of modest bearing and
gentle manner one who spoke fittingly
and had been trained from childhood in
all that belongs to Excellence was
praying with the outstretched hands from
for the whole body of the Jews let me
explain what this means onias was high
priest who had been murdered yeah he was
murdered at this time I want to explain
everyone else guys this is Judas mbes
Judas mccabes is the one who led the
Jewish Army to attack the Pagan Army
from Syria
who had taken the temple defiled it
because of Antiochus this is Hanukkah so
Judas had a vision where he saw onias
the priest who had been killed so he's
seeing him in the
afterlife praying with outstretched arms
now what does that tell you about the
afterlife guys learn about your faith
when you die you don't cease to exist
your soul leaves your body and you still
are consciously Alive Now notice that
onias without his body is still
recognizable and our Lord confirms it in
Luke 16
19-31 where you can still recognize your
dead loved ones why because your spirit
your soul that animates your body when
it leaves your body your body returns to
thus but your spirit your soul resembles
what you look like in the
flesh learn about death and the
afterlife your spirit resembles what you
look like in the flesh so here is onas
and he can see he's stretching out his
hands that means he has a shape and a
form and he knows that's onias and what
is he doing
praying now continue reading for me all
right then likewise a man appeared
distinguished by his gray hair in
dignity and of marvelous majesty and
authority and anas spoke saying this is
a man who loves the Brethren and prays
much for the people in the holy city
Jeremiah the prophet of God pause
Jeremiah had been dead at this time for
over 200 years this is 200 years later
and yet
Jeremiah is
alive he's alert he's aware and he
resembles what he looked like in his
body why because he saw him with gray
hair well what gray hair he has no
physical body are you guys light switch
going on or you guys going to sleep
he doesn't have a physical body but he
still looks the way he did when he was
in his body with gray hair because your
spirit your soul will resemble what you
look like so that in the afterlife you
can distinguish one soul from the
other you can distinguish one soul from
the so now here Judas knows that's not
onias that's someone else Jeremiah is
not onas onias is not Jeremiah he can
see they're different and they look
different but they don't have physical
bodies they're souls and what does
Jeremiah do look what it says it says he
still loves the Jews and he's still
praying for Jerusalem and the people how
can a dead man love anyone on Earth
because they're not dead they're alive
and how can he continue to be concerned
about his people on Earth because
they're aware of what takes place on
Earth you see why those who believe in
Soul sleep and Pro want to have nothing
to do with this
book you see that yeah I do because this
destroys their assumption it shows the
dead are alive they are alert they can
be distinguished and they still know
about events on Earth and they still
pray for the people of God on
earth now if you don't believe this what
are you going to do with this book
you're gonna say well it's not scripture
by whose authority Martin lufer but even
if you reject its canonicity I'm GNA let
you finish it even if you say it's not
scripture you're stuck because this is a
Jewish book telling you what Jews
believe right telling you what Jews
believe so when they tell you praying
for the that is paganism this tells you
they're stupid because this is a Jewish
book telling us that the Jews believed
you can pray for the dead and believe
that the holy man prophets are alive and
are praying for God's people now finish
it all right
Jeremiah stretched out his right hand
and gave to Judas a golden sword and as
he gave it to he addressed him th thus
take this holy sword a gift from God
which with you will strike down your
adversaries can I ask you a a question
sure how could Jeremiah be holding
anything in his right hand when he
doesn't have a physical
body because he resembles that physical
body he looks like it and God blesses
him to be a to do so still has a
spiritual shaped body yeah right so lie
number one when they tell you when you
die you cease to be consciously alive
that's a lie number
two you have a soul a spirit that
resembles what you look like in the body
which is why you'll recognize your loved
ones when you die this is hope from
Jesus Christ and by the way our Lord
confirms this in Luke 16:19-31 when the
rich man Lazarus Abraham all physically
dead but all aware of the other and
recognize one another without bodies but
anyway finish the last verse and then
all right encouraged by the words of
Judas so Noble and so effect so
effective in arousing Valor and awaking
man manliness in The Souls of the young
they determined not to carry on a
campaign but to attack bravely and to
decide the matter by fighting hand to
hand with all courage because the city
and the sanctuary and the temple were in
danger all right do you have another
question brother so I can move on